d'accord tous les jours nous vivons dans deux puits ces
deux puits nous les vivons ces deux
mondes les sociologues de la société
écrivent et les coachs de vie nous aident à équilibrer
nos vies entre ces deux mondes
bien sûr je parle de notre
vie personnelle une vie où vous connaissez cet univers
que nous aimons où nous pouvons être nous-mêmes
exprimer qui nous sommes exprimer nos émotions
nous avons des amis nous avons nos familles de
bons moments des
célébrations et bien sûr c'est un
monde qui est gouverné par l'amour la confiance et
tous ces bons sentiments que nous avons et
toutes les fêtes  et les bons moments que l'
on passe et que l'on partage avec nos proches
et oui le deuxième monde que l'on
vit aussi c'est le monde du travail
ou du travail professionnel et dans ce monde
les règles sont très différentes les
relations que l'on a avec les gens
sont très  différents ils sont plus formels
et il y a certaines règles pour respecter
certains codes de conduite certaines choses
que j'attendais de nous en termes de performance
en termes d'efficacité et nous avons  Les tas
de mots clés sur les objectifs sur la
performance la viabilité la rentabilité l'
efficacité tous ces mots qui font que
cette organisation ou l'entité collective pour
laquelle nous travaillons et pour la rendre
efficace et la faire fonctionner et survivre
et chaque jour entre ces deux mondes
nous faisons une transition  nous faisons la navette nous passons
d'un monde à l'autre tous les jours
et ici tout le monde a son propre rituel
sa propre façon de passer d'un monde
à l'autre
peut-être que c'est le costume que vous
portez les chaussures que vous portez cela
pourrait être des outils  que vous l'utilisez
peut-être au moment où vous ouvrez la porte
du bureau ou au moment où vous fermez la
porte de la maison tout le monde en fonction de
votre
activité vous pouvez avoir différents
rituels ou même différents costumes
différentes choses que vous faites pour mettre
votre professionnel  masquez la chose qui
vous aide à survivre dans l'autre monde et
parfois la frontière entre ces deux
mondes n'est pas très claire mais bien sûr
le collectif et l'autre  euh, les gens de
ce monde vous rappelleront très rapidement
que oui, vous avez fait un faux pas et que ce
n'est pas le bon type de costume, le
bon type de comportement que vous
devriez avoir dans ce monde particulier, donc
la question est de savoir comment pouvons-nous  rester nous-mêmes
comment rester authentique sans être
vu comme un extrait et excentrique sans
être vu comme une personne marginale comme
quelqu'un un paria donc nous voulons rester
authentiques et en même temps nous
voulons pouvoir nous adapter et performer dans cet
autre monde  et bien sûr je ne
parle pas que de vêtements bien sur pour
299 euros vous pouvez vous procurer le
costume de Steve Jobs ok mais cela ne vous fera pas
réussir dans son monde ce n'est pas ce
qui vous rend efficace dans le
monde des affaires de quoi je parle  à propos du comportement
comment nous sommes au bureau comment nous nous sentons
comment ce qui se passe avec nous lorsque nous
nous déplaçons au bureau ce dont je
parle est le comportement et certains de
ces comportements ne sont pas tolérés au
travail être émotif et démonstratif  ng
peur manifester de la colère manifester de la
tristesse ce n'est pas autorisé au
bureau ce qui est réellement autorisé dans ce qui
est recommandé si vous voulez être un bon
employé ou un bon manager ou un bon
leader et être vraiment performant toutes
ces choses maintenant j'ai entendu  tous ces
mots dans d'innombrables entreprises
multinationales grandes entreprises où
vous avez un
certain modèle de leadership vous avez des
modèles de comportement quelle est la prochaine
tendance en termes de comment nous devrions être
au bureau comment il devrait se comporter quelles
qualités devrions-nous démontrer alors vous
voyez  ici, vous avez des choses autour d'être
confiant vous savez assuré d'être
assertif c'est important dans l'
organisation la deuxième chose que vous savez que
vous voyez autour de ces mots
influence les gens être charismatique
influencer votre équipe s'assurer que
votre équipe fonctionnera au mieux de
ses capacités donc  que l'organisation
peut bénéficier de cette performance et que
vous avez des choses autour d'être très
détaché émotionnellement  détaché alors oui,
vous pouvez gérer le stress parce que l'
organisation est un environnement stressant,
donc bien sûr, vous devez être et avoir une
grande tolérance au stress et être assez
détaché émotionnellement et garder ce masque
de santé mentale chaque fois que vous ajoutez le bureau
mais bien sûr et  c'est pourquoi maintenant vous
devinez pourquoi j'ai utilisé l'image de
Dexter ici bien sûr si nous regardons
tous ces traits, ils sont très proches ou à
peu près très similaires à ce que les
psychologues et les chercheurs appellent les
comportements psychopathes maintenant un psychopathe je
veux dire ils  sont des individus qui ne se soucient pas
trop de ce que les
autres pensent d'eux et ils
peuvent également manipuler les autres pour atteindre leurs propres
objectifs maintenant différents, vous connaissez les compétences que vous
connaissez pour mesurer les comportements psychopathiques,
etc. et si nous les regardons, vous trouvez le
les mêmes types de comportement que je viens de
décrire, ce qui est assez
troublant car cela nous donne l'
impression que l'organisation
encourage le comportement psychopathique au
bureau bien sûr, nous pouvons penser qu'un
psychopathe pourquoi pas d'accord explorons simplement
cette possibilité que le
psychopathe est émotionnellement détaché pas
beaucoup d'empathie qui m'aide à gérer
la crise de stress si mes collègues mes
coéquipiers deviennent très émotifs et
vraiment en train de le perdre je '  Je ne garde pas le
contrôle, d'accord, donc c'est efficace
pour l'organisation, deuxième chose, je
peux être assez manipulateur, ce qui signifie
que je peux vraiment influencer toutes ces
personnes que vous connaissez pour qu'elles suivent mon exemple
afin qu'elles sachent faire ce que je
veux d'elles.  pour ce faire l'organisation peut
réussir donc vous voyez qu'on peut
comprendre pourquoi ce masque psychopathique
disons que vos comportements peuvent être utiles
pour l'organisation sauf que la plupart d'entre
nous ne sommes pas des psychopathes nous sommes des
êtres humains nous sommes sensibles nous sommes émotifs
et même si nous  pourrait porter ce
masque de psychopathie et nous ne pouvons pas vraiment l'
être parce que si vous entendiez le discours du
dr.  Ramachandran, il parle de nos
neurones miroirs, nous avons donc des neurones dans notre
tête qui nous aident à refléter ce que nous voyons chez les
autres, l'aide reflète ce que nous ressentons et ce que les
autres ressentent
et nous avons en quelque sorte quelque part dans notre
esprit, cela se produit également, ce qui signifie
que nous  ne sommes pas vraiment complètement
insensibles à ce qui se passe avec les
autres cela signifie aussi que nous sommes
capables de comprendre les
émotions des autres donc nous sommes des humains à l'intérieur nous
pourrions porter cette coque au travail vous
connaissez ce costume ce masque professionnel
ce monsieur vous savez qu'il pourrait  être sous la
forme d'un costume vous pourriez être sous la
forme d'une expression faciale tout cela que
nous utilisons pour nous aider à survivre au bureau
mais nous sommes nous avons un cœur humain à l'
intérieur et nous pourrions bien penser alors quoi
alors que faisons-nous  avec ça ouais nous sommes des
humains mais nous devons survivre dans l'
environnement de travail donc nous mettons les
psychopathes mon
c'est parti vous savez ce que tout cela signifie
et ce dont je veux parler, ce sont les
émotions parce que le e  les mouvements sont les
choses qui nous font le plus peur au
bureau si nous imaginons que les émotions
sont ce dragon et bien sûr si vous voyez
le dragon le dragon est en fait assez
effrayant et si vous voyez quelqu'un de très en colère
vraiment agressif au travail au bureau
bien sûr, nous ne voulons pas voir que c'est
très perturbateur, cela peut détruire les
relations, cela peut arrêter les performances, etc.,
alors bien sûr, vous savez que les Dragons sont assez
effrayants, nous ne voulons pas cela au travail, mais
nous ne voulons pas tuer le dragon.  parce que
si nous tuons le dragon ici si nous tuons
les émotions si nous supprimons ces
émotions, bien sûr, vous savez que cela signifie
que nous cessons d'être humains,
nous enlevons une partie de nous-mêmes, donc nous
ne voulons pas tuer le dragon que nous ne voulons pas
vouloir tuer les émotions ce que nous
voulons faire est d'apprivoiser le dragon en faire un
ami d'accord comme nous l'avons ici et donc nous
revenons à l'essentiel, revenons à l'
intelligence émotionnelle et Daniel Goleman, vous savez,
est écrit à ce sujet il y a des siècles et des siècles des
entreprises  savoir  w à propos de l'intelligence l'
émotion c'est généralement parfois bien la plupart
du temps cela fait partie de leur
modèle de leadership et ils disent à leurs
managers qu'il faut être un
manager émotionnel intelligent mais la plupart du
temps ce que je vois dans la pratique quand je rencontre
ces managers en formation ils  ne
savent même pas comment utiliser même la première
dimension de l'intelligence émotionnelle
qui est la conscience de soi être conscient de soi
est très difficile pour eux ils ne peuvent
même pas mettre un mot sur ce qu'ils ressentent
qu'ils peuvent penser qu'ils ne savent pas  ils
n'ont pas le vocabulaire émotionnel, donc
la conscience de soi est assez petite
au bureau et le deuxième point est et j'ai
été illustré par Bernie Brown dans l'une
des autres conférences TED également, c'est que
euh nous ne voulons pas en parler  les émotions
au travail parce que ça nous rend vulnérables
ça nous fait montrer qui nous sommes et nous avons
parfois honte d'être émotifs
parce que malheureusement les émotions sont encore
vues comme une faiblesse les émotions sont vues
comme quelque chose que nous ne pouvons pas  avoir
quelque chose de moche quelque chose que
vous savez que nous sommes vraiment vous savez quelque
chose de monstrueux qui ne peut pas exister au
bureau, alors quand je suggère en particulier aux
managers parce qu'ils montrent en quelque sorte
l'exemple ainsi qu'à ma population avec
laquelle je travaille la plupart des  le temps donc je
suggère aux managers si vous voulez être
vraiment efficace et être humain et
travailler avec des gens dont vous avez besoin d'être des émotions Des
managers augmentés ce qui signifie que vous
devez avoir non seulement une acceptation de
vos émotions et l'utilisation de vos
émotions donc  ici ce n'est pas cette chose dont
on veut se débarrasser mais quelque chose
qu'on veut utiliser parce que ça peut nous rendre
plus puissant plus influent plus
efficace plus empathique et je vais
vous donner trois exemples trois
illustrations sur comment les émotions peuvent fonctionner
à  le travail peut être utile au travail et le
premier premier exemple est quelque chose
qui m'est assez cher parce que la colère en
tant qu'émotion est assez difficile
au travail vous savez parce qu'on voit toute cette
viole  nce qui peut être déclenché par la colère
mais la colère quand elle est canalisée quand elle est
concentrée et vous pouvez voir ici que le poing est
un grand symbole de colère et mais quand il est
canalisé dans un discours quand c'est un canal
pour conduire le changement, cela peut être très puissant
parce que la colère donne  toi l'énergie la
persévérance la motivation pour aller briser les
obstacles pour aller changer le monde
pour aller changer l'injustice se battre pour
quelque chose en quoi tu crois alors
bien sûr la colère comme émotion peut être très
utile pour l'innovation pour changer une
organisation le deuxième exemple et
c'est  celui que j'utilise beaucoup parce que je fais des
formations sur la
gestion des conflits et montrer de l'émotion dans le
conflit a été vu comme oh non tu sais
c'est comme le conflit il y a un mur
entre nous et ils vont
m'attaquer et je vais  pour riposter donc je
ne peux montrer aucune vulnérabilité parce
qu'ils vont l'utiliser et m'attaquer
mais le fait est que vous devez
adopter une autre approche avec la
gestion des conflits si nous sta  rt montrer notre
émotion pendant un conflit si nous commençons à
montrer une certaine authenticité montrer notre
dureté montrer
comment ce conflit nous affecte comment nous nous
sentons blessés vous faire acheter par l'autre
personne nous envoyons en fait un message
à l'autre partie qu'il y a un
être humain dans  devant eux maintenant, nous ne sommes pas
l'ennemi que la chose que vous savez
contre laquelle nous sommes un être humain
et cela peut être assez désarmant pour les gens
et généralement ils arrêtent de se battre quand ils
voient qu'en fait ils blessent bien une
personne à moins qu'il n'y ait  sont de vrais
psychopathes pensant et c'est une erreur qui
se produit donc pour résoudre les conflits, être
humain et restaurer une
relation de personne à personne peut être très constructif
et aider à résoudre les conflits de manière
beaucoup plus rationnelle, car maintenant nous voyons
où les êtres humains n'étaient pas là pour
blesser  les uns les autres faisons
quelque chose et résolvons notre conflit et
le dernier exemple pourrait parler à certains
des entrepreneurs dans la salle et
essentiellement lorsque vous êtes présent  nting pour un
pitch vous voulez convaincre les investisseurs vous
voulez convaincre des clients potentiels
partenaires commerciaux vous utilisez généralement la
narration et dans les histoires c'est
là que nous montrons des émotions parce que l'
histoire n'est une histoire que si elle parle de
vous si elle parle de quelque chose qui
il vous est arrivé comment vous avez eu une
idée ou peut-être comment vous résolvez le problème de vos
clients ou clients potentiels et
leur problème peut également être
lié à leurs émotions, car
évidemment s'ils ont un problème et
quelque chose que vous savez est vraiment  une douleur
bien ici est l'émotion pour eux, donc
lorsque vous racontez comment votre
produit, votre service ou tout ce que vous
faites résout, cela améliore leur
vie en résolvant ce problème, vous vous
connectez à leurs propres émotions, alors là
encore les émotions  peut être très puissant en
termes de technique de balise influente, donc
ce sont mes trois exemples, mais
bien sûr, lorsque vous retournez au travail le
lundi, vous n'aurez peut-être pas de conflit  ct dans
votre main pour résoudre, vous n'êtes peut-être pas très en
colère ou vous n'avez pas comme un grand
changement pour
démarrer votre entreprise ou vous ne présenterez peut-
être pas ou ne présenterez pas la semaine prochaine, alors
bien sûr, vous savez comment utiliser les émotions
de ma journée pour  jour au travail ou comment puis-
je restaurer les émotions au travail si je ne suis pas dans
ces situations spécifiques et bien la première
chose qui me vient à l'
esprit est juste quand vous entrez dans le
bureau et que quelqu'un vous demande comment vous
allez  généralement, ce que nous faisons, c'est que nous mettons
le masque psychopathe ou que nous l'avons mis
avant d'entrer dans le bureau et
selon nos rituels oh donc nous avons
le masque psychopathe que vous connaissez qui survit
au bureau et nous disons oui je suis  bon
ouais je vais bien toi ouais et c'est tout ce
genre de chose automatique où rien
ne s'est réellement passé, c'est juste ce que vous savez,
ce qui signifie en fait que rien
n'a aucune valeur, alors ici, ce que je suggère,
c'est en quelque sorte d'enlever temporairement le
masque de psychopathe et  peut-être dire quelque chose de
vrai sur vous-même dans  au lieu de dire
oui, je vais bien, dites simplement oui, j'ai passé un
excellent week-end vraiment heureux d'avoir eu
ces deux jours pour se calmer parce que la
semaine dernière est vraiment très difficile au
bureau ou peut-être que vous pouvez dire quelque chose
comme vous savez que nous avons ceci  nouveau
projet cette semaine je suis un peu
inquiet à ce sujet tu sais j'ai besoin d'aide
tu sais tu es vraiment en colère
tu sais ils ont changé ce nouveau
département je ne sais pas comment je vais
gérer ça toi  sais et et c'est
vraiment un isme est un cauchemar pour moi
maintenant à toi de voir ce que tu en fais mais
restaurer un peu d'humanité dans le bureau
passe par les émotions donc j'espère
que euh dans ces 18 minutes ils n'en ont
que quelques  Il reste 30 secondes et que j'ai
partagé avec vous ce message de remettre l'
humain au coeur des entreprises
et aussi de laisser les émotions prendre
la place qui leur revient au bureau merci
beaucoup
vous